joining us now is cbs news political
analyst and kenosha native reince
priebus who traveled to wisconsin with
the president
he previously served as the president's
white house chief of staff as well also
with us cbs news political contributor
joel payne
he is the former director of
african-american advertising for hillary
clinton's presidential campaign good
morning to both of you
uh ryan i want to start with you because
you're exactly the person to talk to
this morning
because you're a kenosha native and not
too long ago you were calling for the
renewal of the republican party by
broadening the base reaching out to
minority voters
the president yesterday seemed committed
to a very different strategy he only
visited sites of destruction he praised
law enforcement
he did not acknowledge systemic racism
has he given up
on trying to broaden his appeal
well first of all you're right i'm from
kenosha spent my entire life
in kenosha my parents live in kenosha
i think yesterday was really for kenosha
itself
more of a thank you
for freeing and saving the city
of kenosha and i can tell you it's not
spin
people were very afraid in kenosha
businesses were burned down
people were locking their doors in their
houses putting kids in basements getting
their hunting rifles out because they
were scared for their life
and i think that while many of the
things you're seeing
are important and i'm happy to get to
those i think you're
missing in your intro and the seven
o'clock hour your intro here
you are missing and dismissing the fear
that people have in this country for
wild
violence put on by people who are coming
out of town
destroying cities and businesses and it
needs to be addressed
first mr president and do do things like
that jacob blake shooting need
address absolutely but you can do both
things
you can address the issues i agree you
can do both things that is exactly and
you can
make it right doing your setup president
is ridiculous this has nothing to do
with broadening
the base of the republican party yes the
republican party needs to add they need
to multiply
they can't subtract people out of the
room and they need to talk to people of
all races
all backgrounds and talk about the
issues that matter in america well
mr priebus you can do both things and my
question pertains to why the president
has not been doing both things he's
talking only to one side of this issue
and not acknowledging the grievances of
the many thousands of peaceful people in
the streets not only in kenosha
but in cities all across the country i
want to bring in joel right now to get
his reaction
uh to what you've just said ryan and
also to talk about
uh the president's strategy overall
versus joe bidens joel what do you think
well i think tony i think your lead in
makes sense
i do think the president needs to be
talking to both sides i think that's
what the moment calls for right
it's presidential leadership and we
actually see that
the strategy that the president and his
allies have been trying to
deploy here which is to make this about
violence when we know
that violence is down across the nation
it's up in some cities but it's down
broadly
across the nation it's not working um
national polls have come out today have
shown that
the president did not get any bounce
from the rnc where they talked about
this issue ad nauseam
and i think um the president is
misplaying his hand because
what he's thinking is that this is a
suburban strategy where you're gonna
you're gonna scare people in the suburbs
so it actually what it's doing it's
backfiring
because many of those people in the
suburbs don't like it when the president
talks about race because they don't
trust him
on this issue of race and unity and
bringing people together
reince it's true what you're saying in
terms of people were very glad to see
him yesterday there
i saw the crowds lined up cheering the
president on as he drove by but
this is the thing that is so hard for
people to take
everybody agrees that the looting the
violence nobody on either side likes
that
but it seems that the president only
denounces it when it is against
him he doesn't he he doesn't seem to
embrace the violence on both sides and i
think
that's what many people are struggling
with so i'm wondering how do you address
it he condemned the protesters as thugs
but on the other side when he was asked
about kyle uh runs from the the young
man with the
with the weapon house written house
when he was asked about that he seemed
to be giving him a pass and i think
that's why it's so difficult because he
seems to be sending
mixed messages do you disagree with that
premise
i i think you know look well first of
all there's a lot of things you said
there gail first of all i think he's
very focused on portland i
you know i don't think anyone thinks
he's he's politically
going to do much in oregon but he's very
fixed on portland he wants the people in
portland
to do what the people in kenosha and
wisconsin did
by asking for help and having people
work together so i i do think it's
across the board
i've never seen anything in my life i've
been doing politics and kenosha since i
was 16.
i've never seen the city of kenosha
which is
65 percent democrat lying the streets 99
of the people saying thank you i'm sure
a lot of democrats are out there too
but i do think he addresses it in his
way when he says look
i know that there are bad apples in the
police force am i willing to say
that there is a systematic
across-the-board
racism within our police i think that's
a that's a road to fire
the last thing i'd say is even on cbs
this morning you had the attorney
general
of wisconsin on your air and he wouldn't
condemn the police because he's got an
ongoing
investigation to find out what in the
world happened how could it be possible
for a police officer to shoot someone in
the back seven times
i mean the clip itself seems impossible
to accept but at the same time they have
to do an investigation
i don't know if there's some wild piece
of evidence here that might
make this this makes sense but it's
horrific
i don't think it does make sense but i
also believe that we
need an investigation to take place so
we can see exactly what happened
i do think there are issues in in
policing that need to be addressed the
the sheriff yesterday
and the police chief one republican i
don't know what the police chief is
they both said on the first question we
need to have body cameras here
in wisconsin we need to have body
cameras in kenosha so they're moving
forward with that
joel how do we advance the conversation
when
people can't acknowledge that there
seems to be systemic racism and and i
i think right all you have to do is look
at the numbers the numbers of
black people who are killed by police
compared to the number of white people
that are killed by police
clearly there's a problem and it's
always reduced to there are just a few
bad apples
we nobody wants any bad apples and
people want
justice they want people and when when
it does happen they want
police to be held accountable and
heretofore that does not seem to be the
case and i think that's why it's so
frustrating but joel i want you to pick
up
the question about systemic racism
because
the two sides are so far apart obviously
yeah obviously there's there's systemic
racism and i think the president is
holding on to this talking point of not
wanting to acknowledge that
because he knows that law and order that
police that support for the police
across the board
is an important issue to his base and i
think he doesn't want to
harm his political base but what he is
not realizing is that the moment calls
for
presidential leadership which
occasionally calls for you
to talk to your supporters about
changing their attitudes
and the president has not shown that he
has the ability to do this
and by the way he has tried to push joe
biden into a place that he's
uncomfortable and actually think that
backfired because
we saw joe biden very forcefully talk
about the looters and the protesters
uh rather the looters and the violent
protesters being wrong but also
addressing those systemic issues there
so joe biden is showing you can do both
donald trump has no interest in doing
both yeah all right reince priebus and
joel payne thank you both very much very
interesting conversation